yeah hi um thanks for coming to my talk
my name is noah fleming i'm from ucsd
and this is joint work with tony potassi
and robert robert
so i'm going to be talking about
extremely deep proofs and i promise by
the end of this talk you will have seen
some very deep proofs
um okay uh so this this talk is going to
be about trade-offs which are you know
pretty ubiquitous phenomenon in
complexity theory um so very recently
several works have exhibited kind of a
new type of trade-off a particularly
strong type of trade-off
and these are known as supercritical
trade-offs
so these are trade-offs where when one
parameter is restricted say
you could think of restricting the size
of a circuit then the other is pushed
beyond worst case so think of
restricting size
and then pushing this causing depth
perhaps to be pushed way beyond worst
case
um so all examples of this phenomenon
have been observed in proof complexity
to my knowledge
so the first instance was by beam
beckham poliatso who showed a
supercritical trade-off for resolution
between
proof size and another notion which is
proof space
a second and
uh
particularly relevant uh work
um
was by rasparov who showed a
particularly strong trade-off for
tree-like resolution
um he showed if you if you take tree
like resolution and you restrict
the width
um that it's allowed to use
then
there's a cnf formula
which requires doubly exponential size
and following this there's been up
several other works
that proved trade-offs between size and
space and also width and space for
various proof systems
okay um
so in this work um we exhibit the first
supercritical trade-off between size and
the very natural uh proof parameter
depth
um
okay so i'll motivate depth in a second
um and we prove such a trade-off for
resolution kdnf resolution
as well as cutting planes
okay and and for today i'm just going to
focus on the resolution proof system
because it's it's the simplest
and
our tradeoffs for these other proof
systems
follow from the trade-off resolution
okay so what's resolution um
so it's a method for proving that a
given cnf formula is unsatisfiable
so you're given a cnf formula and you
interpret it as a set of clauses
so i've written an example down at the
bottom
and you're allowed to derive new clauses
from old ones uh using the following
rule basically it's called the
resolution rule and basically what you
do
is you take two clauses containing
complementary literal
and you take their disjunction that is
it's called resolving these two clauses
so you take their disjunction and remove
the complementary lateral
um so throughout this talk i'm going to
denote by pi a uh just a proof
um so we can take these two clauses and
resolve them to get x3
um and our goal
at the end of the day is to derive the
empty clause the empty clause is
falsified by every truth assignment
and because resolution is sound that
means we can only make like true
inferences that if we derive the empty
clause this means that there couldn't
have been any truth assignment which
satisfied the initial formula
so we can keep going we can take these
two clauses and derive not x3 and then
using the resolution rule on them we can
derive the empty class
okay so this is a simple resolution
proof
and the complexity parameters of
resolution that we're going to care
about are first of all size
just the total number of clauses in our
proof of the number of lines
in this case it's seven
width which is the maximum number of
like variables in any clause
so you can see some of the initial
clauses have uh two variables they're
with two
um and then finally depth which is the
parameter we're gonna be most interested
in which is the longest route to leaf
path in
the proof so in this case it's three
um you know just viewing the proof as it
as a tree or as a deck
okay and i'm also going to use this
notation
um
so size sub res of f for a cnf formula f
is the minimum resolution proof the
minimum size resolution proof of f
and similarly for width and depth
okay
um
so
depth i claim is an extremely natural
parameter of proofs
um
so it's kind of analogous to circuit
depth so if you think about circuit
depth it essentially captures a notion
of parallelism of
a circuit and
you can think of the same thing for
proofs
so resolution proofs capture the
complexity of modern algorithms for sat
so if we prove lower bounds in the size
of resolution proofs then this implies
lower bounds on the runtime of these
algorithms
and lower bounds in the depth imply
bounds on parallelizability
now it's important to note that
every cnf formula has a resolution proof
of depth n so like linear depth however
um
this size may blow up to be 2 to the n
also many strong proof systems can be
balanced where balanced means that you
can take a proof
with size s and turn it into another
proof
with both size maybe polyes
and depth which is logarithmic in this
size
however so this can be done for like
frago or ac zero fragrance strong proof
systems like that however for weak proof
systems
they generally can't be balanced in
particular for resolution kdnf
resolution and cutting planes
these all can't be balanced
okay and we show
an extreme case of this in this work
so this is our main theorem
so if we let p be any of these proof
systems resolution kdnf resolution or
cutting planes
then there's a cnf formula on n
variables
such that there's a polynomial in n size
proof of the formula
however any sub-exponential size proof
must have depth which is polynomial for
some polynomial that's greater than n so
super critical
and our trade-off is smooth so we can
actually ramp this up
um
we can show that
there's a cnf formula on n variables
which has a weekly exponential size
proof so like 2 to the n to the epsilon
[Music]
or delta in this case
however any sub-exponential size proof
must have weekly exponential depth
so what this means is that we have this
proof of
uh two to the end of the delta size
but its depth is basically equal to its
size like it's just a really really long
skinny path um it's kind of a really
paradoxical proof
um so our general theorem is the
following so we're going to let epsilon
just be some arbitrary uh non-negative
real value
and c is going to be another real value
parameter
which will control our trade-off
okay so then there's a cnf formula on n
variables such that there's a resolution
proof
of size n to the c
2 to the order c
however any resolution proof of size
roughly sub-exponential
must satisfy the following relation
that the depth of the proof times the
log of its size
has to be about
n to the c
okay and so instantiating
the value of c here will give us the
previous two trade-offs that i showed
you and you know smooth results in
between
there's one caveat to our result
is that
while the result is super critical in
terms of the number of variables
the formula itself may have end to the
order c many clauses and so not be super
critical in terms of the number of
clauses so super critical in terms of
the number of variables not clauses
and we'll come back to this later
because this poses a problem in some
open work
okay
um
yeah so what is our proof technique
um it's called hardness condensation and
this technique was introduced by
raspberry
so the whole idea is to
to find a cnf formula
on capital n many variables
such that that formula has small size
proofs
but requires large depth so for
resolution we can just take the pebbling
formulas
these have linear size proofs but
require depth which is like n over log
then what we want to do is we want to
compress the number of variables of the
formula
to some little n which is much less than
capital n while maintaining that both a
and b hold
at least for small size groups
and the whole upshot of this is that the
new compressed formula requires still is
going to require approximately capital n
over log n many variables um capital n
over log n depth
but has only little n many variables
so if
little n is sufficiently small then we
get supercritical trade-offs
so how do we do this compression
well the answer is lifting so what is
lifting you've probably all seen it
it's basically one of the most powerful
tools we have for proving lower bounds
and it's just composition
so i'm going to describe it in the
setting of proof complexity so we begin
with a cnf formula on variable z1
z capital n
and we're going to let g be some
function on t input bits
which we're going to call
our gadget
and now we can obtain a new function or
a new cnf formula
which we call the composed function
or the composed formula by replacing
each variable zi with this gadget g
on a fresh set of t variables so you
should think of x i as being a vector of
t new variables
okay
um so these vectors of new variables x1
to xn are typically disjoint and this is
a little bit of foreshadowing
um and then so what a lifting theorem
does is if we let p and q be proof
systems then a lifting theorem relates
the complexity of p proofs
of f
to q proofs of the composed function f
composed with g
okay so a very simple example is if g is
the two-bit xor function
uh so in this case um you know
f composed with xor two we now replace
each variable with a parity of two new
variables so for example replace set one
by x1 parity with y1
and we can prove the following pretty
simple size to uh with the size lifting
theorem
so which just says if we start with a
cnf formula f
than any proof pi
of the composed function f composed with
xor 2
must have size which is lower bounded by
exponential in the width of the
uncomposed function
we're said differently what we're doing
is is we're
lifting lower bounds on the width of the
uncomposed function
to
lower bounds on the sides of the
composed function
and also we can maintain that the depth
of this proof has to be at least the
depth of proving the uncomposed function
so this is a pretty simple with the size
lifting theorem it can be proved by a a
pretty standard
random restriction argument
okay so in this case p is the resolution
proof system and so is q
but we're lifting one parameter to a
different parameter
okay um and one thing i should mention
is that this with the size lifting
theorem is almost tight
so if f has
proofs of size s and with w
then the composed function
has proofs of size
s
times 2 to the w
so up to this s factor
this lifting theorem is tight
um and you can show this just by
by basically simulating the proof of the
uncomposed function to prove the compose
function uh where at every step um you
just kind of locally simulate each xor
and so the upshot is that the naive
simulation is essentially the best just
simulating the proof of f but
at every step just dealing with the xor
and this naive simulation being the best
is kind of a general theme of lifting
theorems and we'll come back to this
okay so typically in lifting theorems p
is a weak proof system q is a strong
proof system and a lifting theorem shows
that the most efficient q proofs of the
composed function
um are just to simulate the most
efficient p proofs of the uncomposed
function with a little bit of overhead
to handle the gadget
but our lifting theorem does the
opposite
so it lifts depth lower bounce on a
strong proof system two depth lower
bounds on a weaker proof system albeit
the new depth or balance we get are much
stronger
so here p is resolution and q
is size bounded resolution so resolution
where we're not allowed to exceed some
size bound on the size
okay
and our proof idea is the following
we want to find a gadget g
such that the number of variables little
n of the composed function is much
smaller than the number of variables the
uncomposed function capital n
and then we want to show that any small
size resolution proof of the compose
function will require basically the same
depth
as just proving the uncomposed function
okay
so in order to do this we need to define
what our gadget is
so
our gadget
is just going to be the xor function but
with a bit of a twist
um
the twist is that these variables that
each xor depends on so you should think
of
x i as being a vector of variables
so the sets of variables x
1 to x capital n will no longer be
disjoint this is unlike the with the
size lifting theorem i showed you a
minute ago
um and the fact that they're no longer
disjoint will allow us to compress the
total number of variables
um yeah so composing will reduce the
total number of variables to little n
which is going to be much smaller than
capital n
so to define our xor gadget or or the
way we allow these expert
gadgets to share variables
uh we're going to use
a simple like bipartite dependency graph
to represent this
so capital n um you know is the is the
number of initial variables so we're
gonna have capital end left vertices
um and here capital n we're actually
going to set to be n to the c like
little n to the c
and the number of right va rate
variables is or right vertices is little
n
and now there's an edge between
one of the initial variables
the original variables to a new variable
if
the
um
original variable is replaced
after composing by an xor
involving that new variable
uh okay yeah so uh this is basically
just saying what i just said um
so we're gonna let f composed with xor
sub g so g is defining the dependency
graph here
uh it's gonna replace each variable zi
with the parity of all of the variables
that are adjacent to it
so here's an example
so you can see that z1 gets replaced
with x1 parity with x3 z2 with x1 parity
with x2 and so on and so forth
so in this way
we can define these xor gadgets that
share variables
so a simple example let's say that z1 or
not z2 and z5 is a cnf formula
we compose it with this xor gadget then
what we're going to get is this so we
replace z1 with its xor
so
x1 parity with x3 and so on and so forth
okay
and then
so
um
one issue with doing this composition is
that since we're shrinking the number of
variables doing this composition can
introduce some dependency
between variables for example you can
see that z1 depends on
x1 and z2 depends on x1 so if we learn
if we learn the value of z1 if
resolution learns its value
then it also learns some information
about z2
and that can be bad because it can
lead to like some really annoying
like correlations so we want to avoid
this
the way we're going to avoid this
is we're going to require that g is
sufficiently spread out
so if g is sufficiently spread out then
learning the value of one xor
won't reveal much information about any
other
and this allows to show that the best
resolution proof of the composed
function
should essentially be to simulate the
best proof of the uncomposed formula
and by spread out we're just going to
mean that g is sufficiently expanding
okay
and then so our final gadget is going to
be xor sub g for some expanding g
okay and um
so the mean workhorse of our tradeoff
is going to be the following depth
condensation theorem by raspberry so he
stated this for tree-like resolution but
it's not difficult to see how to extend
it to resolution
so the depth condensation theorem says
that
if you take some expanding graph g
some unsatisfiable formula f
then
if pi is a resolution proof of the
composed function
with sufficiently bounded width
um
this r
is uh
uh it depends it r is going to be a
parameter in the expansion um but just
think of the width as being
somewhat bounded
um
then the depth times the width
is at least the depth of the uncomposed
function okay and so one of the big
contributions of our paper is we give a
significantly simplified proof of this
theorem
okay
and
so if you take a moment and you you plug
in for f the pebbling formula
then we
um and we let g
be uh
a bipartite graph with capital n left
variables
little and right variables where capital
n is n to the c
then
uh this becomes that the depth of the
proof times the width the proof
is at least
n to the c over c log n
which is basically what our what our
trade-off should be
except for we have
um
we have width here instead of size
okay
so in order to remedy this we combine
this with the width to size resolution
with the size lifting theorem for
resolution in order to prove our main
trade-off
so here's the width to size resolution
with the size lifting theorem
for resolution
um yeah and so combining this
with the depth condensation theorem
proves the following main result
um which is exactly what i showed you
before
um and now
we the the tradeoffs for the other proof
systems uh can be obtained by an
additional step of lifting
so for cutting planes we use the uh
lifting theorem of uh goose gog
come off and sokolov
and for kdnf resolution we prove of
resolution width
to kdnf resolution size lifting theorem
where the gadget is 2-bit xor
um
by using the switching l lemma of
suckerlin bus and polyetson
okay
um so in the last bit of this talk i
want to talk about supercritical
tradeoffs for other models of
computation
in particular size steps tradeoffs
so i think this is a very natural
question um
we make some preliminary progress on
this question
but i think there's a lot of great open
problems here
okay
um so a very natural model of
computation to look at is monotone
circuits because we know these are very
tightly connected to proof systems
furthermore there are functions
for which
polysize monotone circuits require
a near maximal and over polylog and
uh depth
um so a natural question is can this be
extended to a supercritical tradeoff if
you restrict the size
can you show that the depth has to be
above n
okay
and one thing you might be wondering is
whether
such a supercritical trade-off just
follows immediately from our
supercritical size depth trade-off for
cutting planes
using the method of feasible
interpolation
so feasible interpolation basically
connects cutting planes proofs to
monotone circuits
it shows that for any cutting plane's
proof of uh unsatisfiable cnn formula
implies a monotone circuit computing
some associated function with the same
topology that is the same size and the
same depth
okay so this is where our cavea at the
very start is going to come back and
bite us
so the number of variables of this
formula is actually equal to the number
of clauses of the unset cnf formula that
we began with
and if you remember our supercritical
sidestep tradeoff is only supercritical
in terms of the number of
variables
not in terms of the number of clauses so
the number of clauses is n to the order
c
so
what we obtain is
from this is very strong depth lower
bounds
but they're not super critical
yeah so our tradeoff does not
immediately imply supercritical
tradeoffs for monotone circuits
however a natural approach to getting
these supercritical tradeoffs for
monotone circuits
um would be to improve our
supercritical size depth trade-off for
resolution
to work uh for to be supercritical not
only in terms of the number of variables
but
to be super critical in terms of the
number of clauses
uh so in particular using the standard
using the current lifting theorem
uh from
you know from
resolution to cutting planes of
ggks
in order to obtain a supercritical
sidestep tradeoff for monolith circuits
using interpolation
we would require that the following
conjecture is true
which states that there is a cnn formula
on m clauses
such that any say quasi-polynomial size
resolution proof
um
requires depth
which is at least m times n to the four
this this quantity just comes from the
lifting theorems
so we show that if if this conjecture
holds
then this implies
um supercritical sidestep tradeoffs for
monotone circuits
um we also state the following
um
uh approach for resolving this
conjecture
um
which is to study whether the benzasson
vigorous in size with relation can be
balanced
in particular
we'd like to prove or disprove the
following
that any case in a formula on m clauses
that if there's a size s resolution
proof then this implies that there's a
depth which is at most linear in the
number of clauses
and it satisfies the size with relation
so
the width is approximately square analog
s
okay and the reason why we think this is
a really good problem to work on
uh is that there's a great win-win
situation here
um
in particular a positive resolution
would give a counter example to this
conjecture
and a surprising upper bound on depth
for resolution
whereas a negative resolution would give
a conditional
potentially conditional
size depth trade-off for monotone
circuits
conditional here just means conditional
on like a significantly powerful lifting
theorem from
resolution to cutting planes so it
depends on
the
the degree like the the parameters of
your negative resolution
um and the final question i want to end
with
is just whether you can prove
supercritical sidestep tradeoffs for
non-monotone circuits of course under
some
like assumption like cryptographic
assumption or something like that
all right
yeah thanks for sticking with me